since a lot of you seem to have enjoyed
my video on Alex Jones this is not the
type of thing that I usually talk about
but I I really do believe that there are
many things we can understand about the
world by looking at these subjects and
so I thought that I would go into a
little more of this question by looking
at the recent appearance of Flat Earth
theories and Flat Earth conspiracies and
looking at what these can mean in terms
of how the world has been going in the
past last moments and understanding what
is this structure that is that is going
on why is Flat Earth reappearing as an
idea
[Music]
this is Jonathan Petro
welcome to the symbolic world
so one of the most surprising things
that have happened in the last few years
has been the reappearance of a Flat
Earth theory on the internet there are
many videos many people talking about
Flat Earth and I think that it's a very
important thing to look at a lot of the
inside I'm going to give you in this
video actually also comes from my
brother Matt super Joe who has from the
right from the beginning of the Flat
Earth appearing online has been sending
me links and has been sending me some of
his ideas based on that and so so I I
have to give credit to him for helping
me see a little bit about how important
this Flat Earth thing is now one of the
very important things to understand as
we look at how strange the world has
become I talked to you many times about
this notion of when what happens when
the the center breaks down and when
things start to move towards the
periphery start to break apart start to
fragment one of the things that happens
at that time is the incapacity to to see
things clearly the incapacity to know
when something is true or false but also
when something is ironic or not when
it's a joke or not and in the Flat Earth
moment we really see it as this
laboratory of strangeness where so many
people who are involved in Flat Earth
are doing it for the laughs are doing it
to poke fun at people at to troll people
so that when people take them seriously
you know they're just laughing a lot of
it is also a way to to make fun of how
complacent we are in our thinking in how
we tend to accept things the way they're
given to us without questioning them
there are of course people who believe
in Flat Earth in of in a scientific
sense there are those people online as
well but even in those people it's very
interesting to look at the arguments
they give for
I the round earth theory was developed
now I am NOT a flat earther in a
scientific sense but as those who know
about me I don't see the world in those
terms I don't see the scientific vision
of the world as being primary I actually
see the phenomenological vision of the
world as being primary that is that our
experience in the world is the first
experience it is the frame out of which
we then interpret the world and so
scientific understanding which is
abstract which is removed from the
viewer I think actually comes second
it's very useful it's very important if
you want to you know make make planes
fly or if you want to make an iPhone
work of this camera or whatever of
course that type of of abstracted and
alienated thinking where you step
outside yourself and try to analyze the
world that way is very important but it
is not the way we live our lives we
don't live our lives in the scientific
world we live our lives in an
experiential world we live our lives in
a in a what I call a phenomenological
world and so when we start to look at
what is happening with this Flat Earth
ideas coming up this is where we can see
that what we're actually experiencing
right now in the world is a return of
symbolic thinking it's happening slowly
we can we can see glimpses of it it's
one of the reasons why I'm making the
videos that I'm making is because I have
perceived that this is going on and so
it felt like it was now time to speak
into these questions what do I mean by
what do I mean by the return of the
phenomenological thinking what we see in
Flat Earth thinking is we're seeing the
empirical logical you know doubt
everything attitude of the scientific
approach we are seeing it eat itself it
is it reach it has reached the end of
its process and it is now cannibalizing
itself one of the things we've noticed
in the last few years has been a lot of
study
which were recognized as being objective
as being true our scientists are trying
to redo the same experiments the same
studies and they're not able to get the
same results and so old studies that
people took for granted are now being
dismissed we can see it even in our own
experience all life we've seen you know
a time in our life where scientists
rigorous scientists were telling us that
we need to eat four food groups and you
know you have to eat all these different
things every day and this is a balanced
diet and now how we're we're finding out
it seems who knows who knows you know to
what extent even this new thing is true
but now all this is being cast aside and
we're being told no that's not the way
our body works that's not the way our
body absorbs nutriments nutrients and so
because a lot of these scientific
experiments are not being replicated
there is a like I said the process of
scientists coming to its end we're
realizing that so many things that we
believe actually pretty much everything
we believe about the world is not based
on our empirical analysis of things it's
based on trust it's based on the trust
that we have in the authorities that are
giving us information this of course for
someone who believes in a traditional
world to believe in a symbolic world
this is not strange at all we we know
that the world is built on trust we know
that the world is built on the trust of
the of that which has been handed to us
before we know that it's built on trust
of the as a Christian of the saints of
the council's of the Church of the Bible
all these things we know because that's
how a traditional world works but the
modern world presented itself as
questioning all those sources all those
authorities and you know we're going to
do the experiments ourselves we're going
to do the we're going to do the studies
ourselves and then we will get a more a
real perception of what the world is
like but in the end what ends up
happening is because we are not doing
those
at least not you and I we are not going
up into the sky and seeing the world the
world as a ball we have to trust those
who did it we have to trust those who
are giving us these extremely
complicated explanations of how we can
prove that the world is actually round
and because of that now the people who a
lot of the people who are becoming flat
earthers are are doing it the it is the
the the system of empirical data and the
system of empirical analysis eating
itself and what's happening is it's
actually bringing back in a very strange
way
I've told I've talked to you a lot about
this double inversion you know where the
the let's say the scientific
enlightenment world view flip the world
upside down instead of looking towards
authority instead of looking towards
essence instead of looking towards let's
say meaning and language as the origin
of reality we looked at the ground we
looked at phenomena we tried to analyse
phenomena itself you know and that that
flip is is major and it has created some
great things a lot of the tools we use
but in at hulls it has also created a
problem and we see it in the meaning
crisis that we're experiencing today is
part of part of that is what led to this
to this situation that we're in and now
that it's upside down when we reach the
end of that we realize that we are still
based on trust and our world is still
based on trust it's just we decided to
trust other people not not to be not the
same people that the ancient world
started to trust and so it's it's it's
happening in a mythological way this
whole flatter thing is really a mythical
structure which is showing showing
itself in the world and what's happening
is a return to the basic experience of
the world that you can have and that a
basic experience of the world that you
can have is is true it's true in the
sense that it is true that this is our
experience of the world know
that you know has ever experienced the
the planetary systems that is described
in science no one you know has ever
experienced the earth as a globe we do
not experience that and so at the end of
this process we are flipping back and
returning to a world where meaning is
primary where the human human
consciousness is first in then looking
at the world through that filter of
human consciousness now a lot of the
Flat Earth type people don't necessarily
frame it that way to be honest I don't
think they totally know what's happening
in in a broad scale they're just
doubting everything and doubting
everything and then coming back to and
to the very very ancient cosmic image
you know of a dome and a flat of a flat
surface you know and it's hilarious but
it's also it's it's hilarious because we
are in this moment where where the world
is is wobbly and and nothing is certain
anymore and people don't know what is
true what is ironic what's a joke what's
serious you know if you look at even our
political leaders you know they they
they're you know Donald Trump is is
basically memeing and trolling people
the very president of the United States
is saying things in a manner which is
meant to to create to create this kind
of D stop these civilizations but then
when it what it's leading to ultimately
I believe is a return of the symbolic
worldview and it's it's not just of
course flat earth which which is going
to do that but but flat earth and also
you know this whole science of
consciousness this whole return of
understanding that hierarchies of
meaning are inevitable all of this is
kind of coalescing into this crazy
moment where symbolism is returning and
the image of the dome and the the earth
you know at the below is is really
secretly you could say a
turn to this world of meaning now if you
look at some of the flat earthers it's
very interesting to see what because
obviously they have to to imagine a vast
conspiracy which exists you know from
the time of Copernicus basically up to
today and you kind of have and you have
to wonder like why would they why would
they do this why would they lie
systematically until today why would
they fake all these things you know the
the all NASA and all this why would they
fake it and the solution that many of
them end up coming to is that they did
it in order to subvert the world in
order to to remove God remove all those
things that make the idea that the earth
is the center that man is the center you
know and and they so they're faking all
this conspiracy in order to reduce you
know the idea of man in relationship to
God and and this this notion of of the
human person as the center of the cosmos
and that and earth as the center of the
cosmos and so the truth is that they're
right they're right that that's the
purpose but you don't necessarily have
to posit a scientific Flat Earth in
order to see that you know in the the
change which happened which subverted
this the change which happened which
subvert it and changed all this was the
change from understanding the world as
manifesting itself through the human
person today we could say something like
manifesting itself through the through
human consciousness that without
consciousness the world has no form has
no hierarchy has no structure and so
human consciousness becomes the vehicle
by which the world ends up playing
itself out in its meaning in its
hierarchy and so the the inversion the
subversion by positing a world which is
outside of human perception which is
more real but more real you know we say
that it's more true for example that you
know the the
the earth is turning around the Sun it's
more true than the Sun turning around
the earth but our perception of the Sun
is that it turns around the earth that
is if we view the universe through the
through the guise of human consciousness
that is the first perception you could
say the first perception is that
perception of the Sun going around the
world around the Earth it's not a
mechanical perception it's a perception
which puts meaning first that's that's
the difference now once you flip it for
a kind of mechanical descriptive meaning
that that is the most important then
what you're actually doing is you're
putting the emphasis of meaning them
you're putting the center of the world
outside of the human being outside of of
human consciousness and consciousness
itself as the vehicle for meaning of
course in the traditional manner the
ultimate summit of of knowledge is not
the human person its god but God working
through the human person who is the
image of God in creation so that is the
actual subversion which happened so if
you're interested in that I have given
several talk there's a talk on my
channel called a full of front on the
Copernican revolution in which I discuss
how this change this changed from a
geocentric in the sense of meaning of of
anthropocentric in the sense of meaning
worldview change to this this decentered
universe of mechanical causes you know
what that means for us and how we're
reaching the end of that today and now
we're seeing this flip as we understand
the end of the inevitable me hierarchy
meaning hierarchies of meaning which
manifests themselves in the world I've
also written an article which is called
most of the time the earth is flat and
you can already see in the title that I
am trying to explain how we do not have
to posit other mechanical force
other mechanical descriptions to regain
the the anthropocentric vision of the
world to regain a cosmic vision of the
world in which the human person human
consciousness in which love in which
hierarchies of meaning are the center
and if we look at once we understand
that that's the key the key to
understanding the world is to understand
how our first experience of the world is
is through consciousness and through
that filter then all of a sudden so many
things open themselves up all the
stories all the ancient stories all the
ancient rituals you know the shape of a
church the way that we the way that we
have certain social rituals of turning
around centers of all of this suddenly
becomes clear once we understand that
the meaning that the center of things
that the the hierarchy of things is not
the mechanical description of them it is
the manner in which we experience
meaning through consciousness so I hope
that this is a little helpful in terms
of understanding why something like Flat
Earth theory seems to be participating
maybe even you know despite itself in a
return of a symbolic worldview in a in
watching the analytical empirical world
eat itself
by coming back you know despite itself
to the very very ancient vision of the
world as being horizontal and the heaven
as being circular which has a very
profound meaning I also wrote an article
called heaven is round earth is square
which you can find I'll put all those
links in the description in which you
can read about how the ancient
cosmologies describe the world and why
it's important that they do that and
what it means for us in understanding
how the world lays itself out so I
appreciate everybody watching this I
appreciate all the sharing the videos
and you know as usual subscribe to to my
channel if you find this interesting
there's a lot of stuff about symbolism
on my
channel I want to to say hello to all
the new subscribers that have come
through the through the Alex Jones video
and so thanks again guys if you want to
support the channel you'll also find a
link to that below and I'll see you soon